it's not easy to be a fighter
how it hurts on top
is going to be more fighters needs to be
strong
ah
it has gone well for me you know that always
Saturday little hard but a little sore
middle part of the arms
and the game and I'm going to
happen
and we are in the people
We do not accept material
one
we see let the school take well my
name is teresa guaita
I am one of the fighting cholitas
a woman of polis eresma cholita that
takes the pollera the centers the
oil and braids practically
and the hat do not forget the hat
for cholitas life has not always
been easy
before we were discriminated
this chola told him in this chola
you do not see
and that's why it happened to my mom I
as a child I've heard that
they said and treated him not only line
even the mobility did not let him
go up
are the taxis pick us up the woman from
pollera
I do not know why I do not understand so far
because there is that discrimination
we are all equal we all have a
like a nose an eye we eat we live what
same
we are all the same
as cholita for me it is very important
wrestling has improved the situation
thanks to wrestling not
I trained ten years ago but that's how
professionally five years ago
from the ring
how he hurts himself over the ring
there are some times that hurt me
There are some times I hurt my knee
many times I broke my head
people from all countries have the see
exclusively to worley chops
when they are in the fight says not the
fight of cholitas we want to see fight
solo
and that's why I have a lot
pride the pollera
when I'm in the ring I feel
excited and happy I forget then
change my character
ah
I'm proud to be a soloist
fighter
I imagine that future Bolivia
there is an equality there are no opportunities
of work so that
has changed since 2005 thanks to
our indigenous president that we have
Evo Morales
as he did it he took off often he was
He treated the woman in a bad way but
today thanks to him little by little
was changing that from the
discrimination
in the face of discrimination I decree not to
them there may even be a process that
can follow them and put them in jail
and nine of those who say let's say is
we are alone
Juan would be 24 26
nowadays we are taken into account in everything
side
we can see chops in parliament myself
single senators
there is still a lot of economy left
a lot of work but at least light with
my clothes with a lot of pride
two
I go to the doctor when he feels
better nutrition sleep for my daughters
when they are big that help their
neighbor
that do not discriminate against people
if I'm worried, I worry a lot
but I know that someday they are going to
get everything to be happy
ah